it is interesting though that they start
with the pig episode
put off so many people i know like i
know like well i like harry that kerry
watched caught scary saw that i was like
i don't need to watch that show and like
um yeah my business partner alexander
exactly the same like you put off a lot
of people that one episode i liked it i
did too but i wonder why
they did that why start with the only
episode that involves fornicating with
animals
beastie i think it might be because
brooker is
intentionally a bit of a troll i wonder
if that's what it is
hmm
but he might he may well have gone like
this is the one that we'll lose people
on so let's put this one out first and
then we kind of we called the audience
down to like
the people who who have my cynical
streak maybe interesting because it's
not something that like makes people
talk about it in a way that generates
positive press people aren't like like
when people bring up the pig episode
they're not bringing it up in a way that
is like oh i better watch that show
we're talking about
there is that thing when you're making
something that's like deliberately i'm
just turning down my levels a little bit
there's that thing when you're kind of
when you're making something that's like
deliberately niche
um there is that kind of
like perverse version of pr where you're
like actually let's kill let's let's
bring the audience down to people who
will get what we're doing here and then
you can grow it up as a cult thing
rather than because you gotta remember
as well like what are other examples of
that
i i feel like a lot of comedy does it i
feel like a lot of like when you see a
lot of comedy sets like you know special
or something they'll put like the stuff
at the start that's gonna really put off
a chunk of the audience
and then bring them back up i wish
they'd put the trans jokes at the start
instead of writing
did did ricky gervais get you this yeah
i don't even bother watching him to be
honest at this point like that's you
know it's gonna too though like just
that's a shame it's just that's a shame
could you just stop just just stop it
like i get that you're burnt because the
internet is yelling at you and it's
really hurt your ego just stop stop
doing it stop it and they can't help
themselves yeah
no
it's very hard and they do them with you
about everything
and to and for people not to listen to
you i'm sure i'm sure that ego of kind
of a few of these comedians like to have
to just they don't get it i'm right of
course i'm right i'm you know respected
comedian x yeah i think it's so it's ego
it's it's otherwise yeah i don't think
it does it feels that way it feels like
you're watching people who
like especially in the case of chappelle
used to be
the best at what they did he's still
he's been writing brilliant storytelling
oh yeah and even like some of the points
that he can make i can like vaguely
understand i think that there is a very
interesting point
in
if the trans community were entirely
black nobody would care like that's a
point that he's made that i'm like i
think that that is what's himself
interesting
you can make some some interesting
commentary that only you can make um but
everything else
it's just like watching somebody smart
just be really like butt hurt you're
like come on [ __ ]
just suck so bad i think i think they've
not
the aspect that i feel like a lot of
these folks haven't moved with is like
we are a more compassionate society than
we were 10 15 years ago 20 years ago
like in terms of i like that phrasing i
like the phrasing of compassionate i've
always argued i think i think that we're
more sensitive people always say that
but i always say i think we're more
thoughtful we used to stone people on
the streets for adultery
we used to cut people's hands we cover
the curve we've covered the curve
for theft we i mean we've become more
compassionate and less sensitive
it's in you used to in every country
people will be killed for being gay now
only some countries like you used to
go to jail if you swore we've always
been very sensitive very very sensitive
we're less sensitive about a lot of
things more compassionate it's a nice
way to put it i think we're becoming i
think i think that trend is happening i
think there's there's definitely a vein
of comedy that has relied for a long
time on just kind of being a dick and i
feel like and and you know being a dick
up being a dick down but being a dick
generally and i think there's a lot of
comedians who then
you know it's you know it's the chef
that's told you can't use tomatoes
anymore i mean like it's just a tool in
their palette that they're frustrated by
not being able to use them instead of
going hey i should become a better
comedian
they go oh this is someone else's fault
this is
yes this is the world's fault yes and
you're watching very rich
very privileged people
yeah just blast their insecurities over
and over again and it's just
it's plenty of comedians come on man you
could do so much you have actual lessons
to teach that aren't
about the trans community and how you
don't like them like please come on
[ __ ] hell or about how you can't do
you know the whole like you know you
can't even talk about this and then
you're saying that in a special you've
been paid a significant oh it drives me
nuts that that there's this whole
marketing
it i mean they they don't address like
it's marketing this whole rhetoric that
comedians are being cancelled
but then every single one of their
specials is titled not pc
or like
you know controversial uncanceled like
like all of you
that's triggered exactly five comedy
specials are called all of them and they
all say in the description something
along the lines of like says jokes
you're not allowed to say in 2022
like none of you are being you're
getting millions of dollars for these
specials stop complaining about how
you're being [ __ ] cancelled you're
not i do think i do think one aspect of
this um from like a sociological level
just to play watch listen the [ __ ] out
of this conversation it's a theological
level sociological level i do think i
remember when i was a kid there was
plenty of comedy that was like you know
back in the 90s was considered like like
prop like the the big one for me as a
kid was there was a lot of older
comedians who were still doing racist
material who were just like literally
just doing comedy voices of various
groups right and completely
he did he was part of that generation
now
the newspaper oh okay yeah he's still
yeah well exactly my point is though
that there would no i'm talking about
like i'm talking about like yes people
like the 90s like
but they're the guys the guys who had
fame in the 70s but were still around in
the 90s my point is
they weren't
in the mainstream they weren't i mean
some of them were like there's a guy
bridge community called jim davidson who
like was who hosted a bunch of tv when i
was a kid while doing the the kind of
those awful 70s racist jokes as well
like on the side but mostly they were
kind of pushed off to the side i think
one of the reasons this feels like a
very modern thing of the older comedian
who's still doing the jokes that are 20
years out of touch is that the way we
consume all this stuff on like netflix
and stuff you're seeing it i guess
that's my point is the the ricky gervais
of the 90s the guy who was like you know
whose best stuff was 70 years ago with
his comedy co-writer who no longer works
with him i still think some of these
things can't get access to like some of
what he does oh he's got he's he's got a
talent i mean
like
turns out quite a good show
oh the office is great um but i i
definitely am following merchant's
career more than juveces in terms of
like my interests going like you've seen
like um i don't actually know what
either of them is doing what is merchant
up to
merchant did um
oh god what's it called fighting with my
family was really surprisingly good what
did you see that no that is a wrestling
i've
the comments will say what the name of
the the
it's the it's a a biopic of a of a wwe
wrestler but it's the funniest [ __ ]
thing
um
what's it called fighting with my family
i think which no one saw
but basically is where you know florence
pugh it was one of her big kind of that
and midsummer she's like her big
breakouts
i i don't know she looks so american
that it's hard to
she does look american i know what
you're really
visually american
fighting with my family am i getting
that right because it's one i recommend
to people because it's it looks if you
look at like the box art you look at
like you can absolutely rule the hours
oh and it's you know it's wwe funded it
so it's a bit propagandistic for like
their thing but like it's genuinely
paige that's the name of the wrestler um
was like a
you know a big
uh kind of iconic wrestler it's that but
stuff like that like yes so stephen
merchant is doing a lot of comedy
writing he was on conan's podcast
recently he's really just really funny
and good
um
and then yeah
and his stuff
is very inclusive and awesome and yeah
he's seen the idea that like um all woke
stand up is bad or work comedy is bad
you seen this have you heard about this
there's like this rhetoric that like
what comedy is terrible but like bo
burnham's inside is
like that's what comedy excellent that's
what comedy and people [ __ ] loved it
like that's and it was so many good
communities and james a caster i know
that one clip of james i cast has been
doing the rounds a lot but he's
phenomenal i wish i knew people's names
i can draw a million faces into my head
of this guy
he's the guy who you've seen a clip of
in the last week with um in a blue and
pink uh uh jacket talking about am i too
is that controversial for you that guy
oh i did see that clip yeah you did see
that yeah it went round yeah um
i'm obsessed with auntie donna like and
there's so there's a lot of australian
great australian comics at the moment
i'll get through all of them
get that australian inclusion in
appreciate that appreciate that yeah
there's loads of really good comedy
because what's interesting is like all
great art and design
when you have a constraint and the
constraint is we're not just going to be
mean to be be nice it's hard
but that constraint creates great
solutions comedians have to find new
avenues for comedy and that's really
exciting and leads to really good new
[ __ ] yeah and also in the case of auntie
donna like a lot of like monty python
ship basically which which hasn't been
done for a while so yeah it's cool
there's a lot going on welcome austin
how are you doing you also wearing blue
for the state of play today video games
star wars sorry i'm catching up quickly
yes comedians and cancel culture we're
starting strong this episode
oh man how do you feel about this pig
episode of black mirror austin
the pig episode of black mirror yeah
pulled from the headlines
um
it's the very first episode
of black mirror
like first ever if we describe the plot
to you we get demonetized so i
must have watched it then but i feel
like
one that no one forgets yeah yeah well
then i guess i i guess i i guess i
watched that show more a la carte when
it became because they were like
because few people like people were like
oh this one's really great this one's
really great i think i started with the
the ones that had all the hype and then
i missed something it might make your
theory right mike that it's like a thing
that you get out people but then the
people who stay in maybe they recommend
totally specific episodes um austin did
you watch the first episode of love
death and robots the the new season
i think so what um do you just not
remember first episode
which one what which one it takes in
like half an hour to wind up it's that
thing where you don't notice the first
four frames of it because it doesn't
remember the first episode of any given
tv show i i've only watched a few
robots the world ended
uh that's been like 50 of the episodes i
know i was gonna say that that's
incredible the one right before the troy
episode
that's the only one that i watched
because that's the only one worth
watching there you go i said it it's
very good i enjoyed it a lot brilliant
that's why it feels weird to talk about
the episode troy is in without troy
being here though we'll try to i think i
haven't i think i didn't watch the first
one i think i have only seen i think i
only so far have had time to see two of
them which was i watched troy's and i
watched the
the like zombie miniatures
one i haven't seen i've heard that one's
good people night of the mini dead it's
very cute
it's very it's a very fun
like i saw people that were like this is
the greatest thing ever and i thought
well that i don't agree with but it's
very i mean there's no bad love death
robots that i've ever seen like like
truly i thought this this first episode
was was bad
nice yeah we were talking about it
before we started recording it was just
like it was and it was very weird to go
from the first episode which i thought
was bad it just
said things that are like
common knowledge almost and acted like
it was smart
all to lead to a punchline
that was very lame like i just it was
just interesting
okay i just i found it very like
eye-rolly um but then to go from that
into troy's episode which is the second
episode which again i still think it's
funny that referring to it referring to
it as troy's episode when everybody else
is referring to it as somebody else's
episode
uh which is brilliant it's really great
for him to help out new directors yeah
that's one of the things about he's so
compassionate with his time yeah just
yeah he gave he gave that guy a chance
it was good places
it was uh i think so it i mean it's not
wrong to call it his episode from the
standpoint that he
is the doc well it's the lead and
dominates the
like the story you know like obviously
it's
it's close to friends with david fincher
though in fairness yeah like i think
that's i think that's possible i mean
who could blame you yeah it's that
everybody else is calling it an intense
david vicious episode and we're like the
troy episode no i loved it i thought it
was i thought it was so
so good i loved the way it looked but it
also just like morally i found it very
interesting
the story is oh yeah yeah it's from a
short story right
uh and uh apparently yes my blue is due
to state of play yes i always theme my
clothes are on playstation i don't i
don't just grab
like the t-shirt from the drawer that is
the exact same i definitely just grab
sort of whatever is nearest and suits
the weather
yeah exactly you do you do look like
every 80s music video distilled into a
human being it's great
you're very welcome it's meant as a
compliment
i finally saw the batman oh yes how do
you feel about that
i finally saw the batman yep yeah this
is why i haven't watched it uh it's
really hard i thought it was fine i me
too i
but you're not allowed to say that
i was entertained yeah except for the
last hour or the last half hour where
you
jesus why is it still going um no i i
people were very upset with me for
saying it wasn't the best thing ever but
i didn't hate it i just didn't love it
it just it i had the same here we go
just just to have have fun with the
comment section um i had the same issue
with it i kind of had with the joker
which is i've seen
scorsese movies and i've seen with this
one i've seen fincher babies first and
and everyone else's seven was better
it was better and you tried to do the
same thing but you didn't do it as well
do you think do you think do you think
that warner is genuinely like a policy
of like we're gonna make
uh
they basically have like a a wall
somewhere like are we gonna like have
they go wall somewhere with like the
seven favorite directors of every film
studies student and they're gonna make
like a movie in that style
like we're gonna hear like superman as
done by nolan i guess well we have that
sorry we've had that no that wasn't a
bit but
i don't think that it's i don't doubt
that they i think the director comes in
and they probably do have like a mood
board like their own little pinterest
where they have this this this and this
it's like these things um for tone but i
don't think that's awesome
which isn't really like anything it was
very good
i really enjoyed that because it felt
like it was
doing cool stuff with the with the with
the characters yeah the um i like the
director i love the planets the apes
apparently the apes trilogy well he did
he did the second the second and third
right but yeah he i think he's great i
just it's it's
so much better than they had right to be
exactly exactly and this i was kind of i
think i maybe went in with two high
expectations because i was kind of
expecting that here as well but yeah i
don't know it's weird seeing batman get
more and more gritty
like over time but at the same time
very cheesy movie
it's well it did
i liked i did love i love the production
design like all that gothic oh yeah all
the gothic interiors and everything like
were beautiful gotham looked awesome but
when i say cheesy i mean like thumb
drive
and you are
l
like there's just a lot of really yeah
it's just like ridiculous cheesiness in
it that is so at odds with how gritty it
is i want it to push more in that
direction i think i think that's part of
it the mafia yeah
it's it's interesting how
did you hang on a conceit
they now expect the or so that was in
that was an interesting thing to me was
they referenced martha um
i'm not gonna go and spoil this but they
referenced martha as put a point in the
story and i don't think if i remember
right i think they just say
martha wayne
and they don't bother to explain that
that's the mum and i wondered if that's
because from a pop culture point of view
everyone now knows that that man's dad
was called martha because of that right
that's a good point
i was like i want that's interesting
because there are certain parts of the
because with all of these superhero
mythologies there's a turning point
where something becomes so known by the
audience as a meme that you don't like
um power and responsibility with
spider-man like there's just these
things that like you can assume that the
average person knows about these origins
so it was interesting that's a
a nugget of information about batman
that's now kind of presumed for the
audience which was interesting well it's
unavoidable like
that that the martha one was so
aggressively memed that i'm seeing
people talk about morbius now where
morbius memes seem to have taken on a
life of their own are we ironically
liking morbius is that where we are as a
culture
it seems that people are doing that no
we're we're not pretending morbius is no
bobbies is actually not that bad really
it's i'm not saying that it's fine
um okay
there are some things in it that are
very silly but it's fine
but maybe i say that because i had
really low expectations but there are a
bunch of like people in the
mobius
meme community who've not actually ever
seen the film they just make memes about
it and that's i guess where we're at as
a society now which
i'm for it
well we do live in a society so far
society hey they said that in one of the
batman movies too
i didn't um
i didn't i saw that you posted a video
of your reaction to obi-wan mm-hmm i
have not watched it what is your
no does it shock you no i'm saying i did
not watch your videos oh i thought you
meant you didn't watch the show you're
shocked you're like you didn't watch my
videos i watched every video you didn't
watch your video he didn't watch obi-wan
he only died
by your reaction videos um
but no what is the
what was the long and short of your
take and or have you seen the third
episode yeah so my thoughts are a bit
different now that i've seen the third
episode
um
and actually before you go in mike are
you where are you at with it i've seen
one and two but not three but
it's fine it's star wars
spoilers do you worry about spoilers we
know where we're going with this that's
true but we could i think we can
avoid them because it did just comment
well it didn't just come out when the
episode whatever oddly one of the
problems with the show is that spoilers
are possible because it totally retcons
the like yeah like they blatantly
contradict things that are supposed to
take place after it yeah so it does have
spoilers
that are supposed to have happened yeah
happen yes and yeah episode three um so
first two i was like things i like
things i don't like um
i think there's an interesting direction
you can go in here i thought that the
chase scene was like so laughably
terrible that it was like inexcusable
um and i i was like okay
she i don't know how to how much i
should avoid spoilers
uh hazardous people
assume most of the audience has seen
that okay
okay so i was like she has a layer has
the potent i thought it was really cute
and she was super endearing but had the
potential to be very annoying and i
wasn't sure where that would go um it's
like i'm interested to see more i
thought the cg was pretty pretty
appalling
um
and
i have issues that i think uh even more
solidified with episode three where i
just do not [ __ ] care about these
inquisitors i don't care i do not think
the storyline of we're all trying to get
promoted even needs to be told of course
they are like i don't know why you even
need to give me a scene of these
inquisitors being like i'm trying to get
on vader's good side no [ __ ] that's like
your whole thing i don't know why i need
to see you talking about it i don't care
at all um is that because you're
familiar with the inquisitors do you
think that like a general audience don't
know i think that you should read two
sith who were like working
under vader
would be competitive yeah well you see
it anyway they just keep having scenes
where they talk about it and they have
this conflict where they're trying to
please vader again as to sith no [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what you're doing like i
don't i i think that anybody would be
able to infer that with zero because
it's not even inquisitors they don't
have to be inquisitors which like i do
know a little bit more about because of
jedi fallen order um it could be
absolutely any
sit
really like you'd be like yeah they of
course they want to be the most powerful
or they want to get into the most
powerful you have to stop [ __ ]
telling me about this just i don't care
about them at all i'd be happy if i
never saw them again but i know that's
not going to happen
no it seems like the entire thing is
framed around them as the actual
villains i think vader being more of a
peripheral figure who's there to kind of
be cool periodically
yeah which i mean that's been made this
job for like 50 years
for a while
um
episode 3 i found deeply disappointing
you know projects like this always have
their challenging situations because
there's a lot of people involved there's
a lot they know it's going to be highly
scrutinized there's big marketing so you
don't just write like as a composer you
don't just write your music and say
here's my
sort of genius vision for this thing and
i'm gonna make my stamp and it's like
of all the properties star wars is
musically one of the most sacred that a
composer could ever have to navigate
which makes it very difficult it's not
about being reverential to the legacy
that john williams has laid down it's
also about the idea of there's a lot of
people who are there to scrutinize to
say
is this
sufficiently
on brand is it sufficiently doing
something new and there's a lot of
people that are gonna weigh in and and
have sway and you're gonna end up having
to do tons of revisions to make sure
that all the various powers that be are
happy that's just a known all big studio
projects have this and with star wars
you're going to amplify
the scrutiny and then you add to that
john williams just sort of mid-stream
shows up and
decides to write the theme and is is
actually involved now so there's another
layer of
political
navigation to just make sure like he's
happy and this is all just this is all
this is not coming from anything she's
told me this is just
knowing how the game is played
and yeah and the inferences um but but
the conversation you know made it sound
like you know yeah like this was a this
was a feat to to pull off for sure she
she she did a very admirable job at
just surviving uh the the the challenges
of both just creatively satisfying it
and also just navigating to make sure
that the powers that be and the
stakeholders are
are all happy somebody's improved who
worked on it um
that i like won't even give insight to
what the
job was who said that
the show went through a lot of
iterations and that he was very upset
that what they had at the start wasn't
what came out at the end they really had
to iterate a lot and change a lot of
things over
meaning um
you and mcgregor yes my friend ewan
mcgregor i thought you oh i thought you
were saying no no no i didn't realize
that i don't want to identify
with my friend danny boyle about it yeah
um
i thought you were saying that like
because sometimes you hear those stories
of like
you know you would have someone like
this show i'm sure was greenlit based on
you and mcgregor and you know what
yeah you know what if you guys show up
with it i'll do it and then like
sometimes you hear stories i haven't
heard that about this one but there are
sometimes things that happen where you
get the person that is the linchpin of
the whole thing to agree to do it and
then by the time it started reaches the
finish line the creative process has
evolved into a thing that's really
different than what they
had hoped for
and then now you're kind of like well
let's just try to make the most of it
i'm not i'm not in no way saying that
was the case here but
but i have heard of other movies i
believe it was originally a big case
um
and as that was dialed back it kind of
hurt parts of the script
i heard that the thumb drive joke was
originally in this show yeah and they
actually moved it over to um warner
weirdly or yeah bizarrely yeah i i uh
it's
complicated
it's funny how in general star wars i
don't think benefits from being dark and
gritty though i do like rogue one the
most by far of all disney era star wars
work and that's like the most dark and
gritty and it's also the time it's the
one time you see
like the most remorseless version of
vader the one that actually acts like he
is
sort of built up to be you get that one
scene in rogue one of him just being
completely violent and destructive
yeah and it's the one it's the one
payoff of him being the vader that
that name implies
and so despite that so i love that movie
to death uh and uh and i just find it so
uh genuinely like heart accelerating you
know but
uh all the rest i've always i felt like
you know it's weird how
there are certain things that feel like
they're
you know it being under the sort of
brand of disney and the certain
family-friendly implications that that
brings
that feel like it's holding it back and
yet i'm like well
but is it because star wars was never
supposed to be this gritty
realistic thing so i find myself
sometimes a little confused about where
i think it ought to go because like
there were places where i thought boba
fett would have benefited from him being
just this cold-hearted killer and like
him being the hard opposite really
sabotaged it i felt and
it was like he's not a bounty hunt like
he was implied to be this absolutely
ruthless beast
again all through implication we don't
never do anything in the originals which
would have done on purpose like you know
he still says it was supposed to be kids
movies
it would have been intentional that you
never saw that
yeah so it's always interesting how you
know once things expand a certain point
and you're looking for places to go you
end up with a challenge of like
how much do we have to abandon the
fundamentals to keep going new places
without just re treading
and i think that's been my
my biggest gripe is this thing is so
it felt like it feels to me like leia is
they looked at grogu and go how do we do
that
but not that
uh sh she was uh i think the kid's doing
a great job though like to be i'm gonna
stand up for that [ __ ] they feel like i
do now too
oh it definitely feels leia yeah i like
it was like i didn't love some of her
acting but i i
especially after episode three i'm like
yeah no she is like
very much leia she's got that essence
down in a really impressive way
i don't think there's an issue with her
and and likewise i think you and
mcgregor is
brilliant [ __ ] awesome so good he
makes
he makes a lot at you know and that
moment
um i actually was moved
like it it it it surprised me that it
surprised me but it did i had a genuine
reaction
um
when uh
that moment in episode two
where she's being all obstinate and
stubborn
and um
[Music]
and he kind of says you remind me of
someone who was a leader and blah blah
and it's like
i that that was a moment where i was
like that's what this show can offer
this connectivity to other things
um
that felt like a nice little moment
where she was
you you can see
the way retroactively when making the
prequels lucas was like
how do we
create a
believable mother figure to leia even if
they never had a mother-daughter dynamic
but there's a certain inheritability of
these kind of like
the you know the sort of courageousness
and the suffer no fools and a lot a lot
a lot of um and uh
a moment to kind of like ping that was
it was nice um i i will also say
in the show's defense
despite the fact that
if i really let if i really kind of get
going i'll turn rather scared i almost
don't need to watch anymore after
episode three
i kind of sadly it's sort of
heartbreaking to me that i feel the same
but
um in its defense
i do think that
and i don't know if it's because of
something as superficial as like it has
you and mcgregor in it i would hate to
think it's
what i'm about to say could hang on
something as super as surface level as
that but
relative to everything else it actually
feels like star wars in the same way
that strange new worlds actually feels
like star trek i love strange new worlds
you know and you know what i mean like
it has that quality where you go it it
feels like and i applaud
like to me one of the strengths of
mandalorian
was that it didn't feel trapped in
star wars
and like i like the ways that it feels
more like a western and pushes off into
slightly different territory so it's i
recognize that i'm being slightly
internally inconsistent by saying
that
uh you know the the rehash elements or
the sort of you know fan lazy fan
service-y things all those hold it back
but yet i i can't deny that that obi-wan
does feel like star wars to me in a way
that is
a point in its favor that like boba fett
i didn't really feel like felt like star
wars
the cg
like i wish there were more practical
effects
well i mean but that's the you know
that's where half of star wars at this
point is
you know like loaded cg and it's really
only the original trilogy like the
original trilogy some of it looks better
than
this tv show that came out this year
it's just wild but i think ewan mcgregor
is enough to carry it like i i like i
said i found episode three extremely
disappointing just
really that's what you did
with
okay
wow okay and then i just sat and thought
about it and was like [ __ ] hell
um
but yeah so she made me more excited to
watch episode three based on that that's
fun
i really do want to talk about it i'm
really it might not bother you it's like
it depends on your level of investment i
think because like my twitter timeline
was covered in people who who was so
happy about it and i was like
okay late bloomer when it comes to star
wars like 100 like i definitely like i
arguably mandalorian was like the first
thing i truly loved like that i was like
i i've enjoyed all the styles but i
would say that was the point where i was
oh i'm also weirdly not a huge star wars
fan like
put myself in that category because
there are people who are just like such
big fans that like i feel like i'm
ushered out by how hardcore some people
like i don't feel like i'm on austin's
level at all
i've been very saturated with star wars
though lately i did um i went on rise to
the resistance for the first time how
was that i haven't done it
incredible like a new stage in theme
park really
stuff yeah damn incredible i had a
friend text me that exact sentiment
yesterday wow oh really yeah yeah he
just went on a whim and was like this is
a game changer whoa it changes
everything yeah it's it's it feels like
a victory lap it kind of it's like a
like like great video games it
incorporates everything that's gone
before it but then just spins it in its
own avoid spoilers like do not find out
anything about it that's an interesting
concept for a bride
wow
if you like the depth of it and the
surprising nature of it wow is
is something it's the first time yeah
where i would care about spoilers with a
ride but someone said that to me when it
first opened so i did avoid seeing
anything i know two now
and it's amazing
it's worth it's worth like like
i don't know if it's worth the price of
admission to the park but it's close
like it's that wow i mean as a star wars
fan i to me that's an easily
justified
you if you're yeah i mean as a star wars
fan
i think you'll cry
moved by how impressive it is like i
think as a star wars fan have you done
that have you been to like galaxy's edge
and stuff since i opened austin actually
crazy enough i haven't uh oh dude it's
one of those classic things when you
live and you live nearby it makes you
don't bother you're huge in position but
if i had to fly across the world there's
like one tourist thing in london
but it's also that like my thing is
so many friends come to visit all the
time like i know that
half of
my friend group in the u.s is going to
be in la next week somebody's going to
ask to go to disney so at least once a
year i have friends who are like hey
come to disney and that's how i end up
going is because people who don't live
here want to go like their friends
coming from australia and stuff next
week for not e3
um so i just i know that i'll go like
it's not a thing where i'm like
like i don't know i don't want to over
hype it but yeah it's that's really cool
incredibly impressive um that and i've
been reading um the i've started reading
the high republic book so i'm in
probably awards mode at the moment nice
yeah
they're good you might like those austin
it's funny also can't read
yeah that's a shame it's true there is
music they have background music on the
audio book so yeah someone sit next to
me and read it to me
i um
it's so interesting how like
i've always been a fairly hardcore
star wars nerd um
and
but i also like i was when i was hanging
out with natalie
um the composer on obi-wan preserve
yeah
we i was telling her how i watch a show
like obi-wan in two places at the same
time where there's a part of me that
very much understands how the industry
works and has huge amounts of
compassion for
just the baseline difficulty of making
anything under any circumstances no
matter what it is like if you ship
a thing
congrats you've done the near impossible
like 99 of things don't it's like how
how in evolutionary biology terms 99
of all species ever have gone extinct
the default state is to crash and burn
and fail or never get off the ground
like that
life and creativity are hard so i will
always have and the more i work in the
industry the more i will just say hey
your thing came out so
my level of judgment already goes down
several notches and i get i get i can't
help but get irritated when i read
fans go
like this [ __ ]
and i'm like make yours that's what i
said like
the one that always annoys me i get
really annoyed when you see like a
critic or a fan say like why did they
even bother making this especially with
video games you think that somebody in
that that room of extremely talented
people didn't think of that and you did
yeah
yeah or there weren't a thousand factors
you know working again like oh you know
we were set to make this feature and
then uh you know a family life crisis
made our art director have to leave for
a month and then we out of pragmatic
reality we had to do this and it's like
you don't ever hear those stories but
there's a there's always something
there's always a thousand things that
are variations on just the intersection
of life the challenge oh it took us an
extra month because
this
network support of this feature that
we're trying to add just never could
work we don't i mean forgot to you know
we've talked on the past uh talked in
the past on here about the denver
airport uh and all the like weird
stories about it from i remember when
they were building it when i was growing
up they built the world's most
sophisticated uh automated baggage
handling system
to and it's to this day never worked
they have always used the backup system
it's like so
making things creativity civilization is
hard so i look at it and i go i look at
the show and i think there's a million
things that i could i could point to
that they're doing right
oh yeah by virtue of the fact that you
know they made a thing and it's got a
lot it's a lot more successful um
original new series launch ever as well
i mean how could it not have been
in a way it would have been baffling to
not have been given that it's
true it's like the the hype and the the
to have scooped up you know
there's that yeah yeah i'm sure it's
but so it's like there's so i watch all
so it's like that's one lane that i'm in
where i'm just nothing but
admiration uh and and like
empathy
for just how hard it is to do [ __ ] and
then there is also the like
super hardcore annoying star wars fan
that's that just is
writhing in agony uh over all the
inconsistencies and all the
the you know sort of like canon
slippage like the first thing i thought
of in the in the beginning obviously
they hid very well the the leia
uh sort of aspect in all their marketing
and making her the kind of
quasi-mcguffin of the show struck me as
a really bold to the point of crazy move
when you figure
her introduction
is seems very predicated on not knowing
obi-wan yeah uh and i was like that
like there's part of me that says i want
to see where this goes
over the six episodes
just to see if they
try some variation on addressing
this foundational
issue
um and uh like similarly to sort of
explain it a way that isn't that always
does that always feel like rational like
a post-hoc rationalization though to be
clear that's how serialized like i've
not seen this so i i don't know what
we're talking about but i'm going to
have an opinion anyway you have seen
this this is episodes one and two how
i'm sorry yeah
but it seems like serializer doesn't
know obi-wan even though she's clearly
met him now based on this
apology she does know obi-wan before you
he only references him as somebody who
worked with her father
yeah she says you served with my father
in the clone wars uh and like
as if i was okay that's the introduction
you know the like
you don't know who i am but you knew my
father and i need your help that was how
that read
um right okay and it was kind of like
remember when we hung out when i was a
kid yeah i remember when you saved me
and like yeah it's it was a little bit
kind of like
yeah so
counter opinion and one that is
a very shaky foundation yeah like i like
i'm not even sure of the argument i'm
about to make
let's do it um
all serialized content requires
retconning there's no there's never been
a story told by multiple authors over
multiple years that hasn't required
subtle editing and changing of
historical events to make it work um if
you the
was it there's some especially once you
reach a critical mass of canon it
becomes completely totally it happens in
star trek i'm a massive part of star
trek i'm massively into star trek i i
could quote every fact in that universe
but in star trek they're constantly
having to rewrite stuff there's a really
good youtuber called um jesse gender who
does a bunch of star trek stuff and she
did a video on this subject within star
trek because the star trek fans get as
annoyed about this stuff as star wars
fans do if not more arguably i'm gonna
say i think they get i think they yeah i
think they get actually more hardcore
because there's just a lot more star
trek in the world
this has always happened like this is
just how i agree with stories you kind
of have to let it go if you want more
content that's how i feel about this
exactly
like the last several mcu entries
they've that canon has started to really
break apart so rapidly like to me i
haven't watched any of the new ones the
combination of doctor strange and loki
and the attorney like i didn't even
watch the eternals but just once you
reach a certain point
it becomes this question of
why the hell where was this person when
that thing happened like
it starts
does that matter though do you think
that that bothers you it bothers me if
it's supposed to
once you've built the premise of the
avengers
it starts to be like you've established
now a thing that makes that a problem um
that's why i think my perspective is
more the kind of canon is important to
the extent that it create creates
interesting foundations for new stories
that's the
and if ever i'm working in franchise
stuff i want people to disregard that
quote and not throw it out
i can imagine an image of my face in
black and white
the second i change anything in any
franchise ever yeah yeah no and that's
the thing and i i like
that's that's again where the parallel
lanes
makes me
i think you can be both of those things
can be right i think it can be
frustrating and you can be allowed to be
frustrated
at the same time oh my god this is going
to take a long time to get out at the
same time that you can recognize that it
kind of has to happen for new content to
exist yeah and i want i want artists and
writers and directors to feel like they
should be able to take risks like for
example in star trek discovery
the idea of making um michael burnham
spock's sister was a
super [ __ ] bold move to to put your
show like here's a character with 40
years of content who's never referenced
having an adopted sister ever and they
found a way to try to canonize why that
would be while also and so there's part
of me which they did kind of solve right
they kind of they did as good a job as
anybody could do i think like they end
of end of season 2 or whatever where
they kind of explain why that's no i
thought that was a good solution to the
problem
yeah two or three no no i think it is
two
the one where they do the montage that
explains why you've never heard about
that character yeah like um yeah yeah i
i it seemed like they had that in mind
from the start because they they knew
they had opened up this interesting can
of worms about spock and a lot a lot and
like there's i can't i can't not admire
the the moxie
of of that it's because it's like don't
hear moxie enough anymore well yeah it's
true you know so that that's what i
again that's the professional
like if i was hired to do a thing
okay so for example there's plenty in
natalie's score that doesn't sound like
john williams knockoff and predictably
there's the contingent of star wars
nerds that go it doesn't sound like star
wars music because and i'm like and and
as a longtime star wars nerd there's
this part of me that goes yeah i get
that it doesn't sound like star wars
music but i go i can tell you if they
hired me the first thing i would do is
go how can i make this not sound like a
john williams knockoff yeah like the
artist always is going to want to try to
do something new and it makes working on
long-running franchises a really
daunting challenge especially of all of
them star wars and so this is i've had
an interesting kind of
revelation watch not revelation but
watching it
where i go i think part of it i think
part of the whole disney plus thing even
despite
the blatant fan service plays that they
make all the time a lot of which really
rubbed me the wrong way and like having
you and mcgregor and which i love that i
don't that wasn't meant to be part of
the previous sentence
um but a lot of the fanservicey things
that to me start to become a problem
despite all that it always does feel a
little bit like
they're making star wars for new
recruits
as much if not more
uh in the same way that like lucas was
always
you know
all the hardcore star wars fans from the
70s 80s 90s who were very very
turned off by the prequels there's so
many interviews you can find from 20
years ago of george lucas going
kids like it and it was kind of for them
and i've started to now meet the 18 and
20 year olds
right yeah there's so many kids that i
now interact with who i had no
interaction with because they were like
nine years old well now it was really
interesting
it was interesting at celebration
because i watched the whole of
celebration because i i'll probably just
kind of fascinate by those kind of
events but but it was interesting what
was really interesting was how much
everyone was praising filoni right
yeah he's he's got he's essentially
right now
he's on massive following and rightly so
he's very good but like i think he
because i think in life
the new david attenborough series today
that's favreau i think you're right
sorry that is february yeah
but
and and that's one that i could talk for
an hour on the pre-story planning oh my
god i love it my issues were still
happening really okay i've been told
it's like because he was basically the
steward during the year you're talking
about austin the kind of that clone wars
well george lucas was also super
involved then you know like like there
was a passing of the torch that happened
and so this new generation who are like
your your current 20 something or early
20-somethings those people who grew up
with the prequels are now
looking at felony the same way as they
your generation looked at lucas yep and
that's really interesting to see that
definitely
and to me the the thing that that i the
reason why i said that i've had a little
bit of a revelation revelation is too
strong a word but like
as a i've i was my own case study of
this phenomenon
because i
uh i watched the halo series i've never
played a halo game in my life other than
at a friend's house multiplayer
intermittently cool neither did anyone
who made that show so you're fine
that's the thing so i watched i watched
the whole season and i was like
look i'm i'm into more
generally i'm into like slightly more
hardcore sci-fi
like the expanse that's that's deeply my
jam by comparison but i have fun with it
i go i i have zero halo
attachments in baggage and i don't and
it's very clear to me from what little i
do know of that franchise that they've
rather substantially made alterations if
you're like me and you're into the halo
law then you probably didn't like it's
really hard to accept it's working for
you that's cool and it made me it made
me it made me appreciate it it put me on
the other side of the fence i think for
maybe the first time in my adulthood
where i watched a thing as a essentially
an outsider that has a huge amount of
insiderness about it that i've just
because of random life i've just not
found myself inside because i would
totally be into halo i just i just never
had the original xbox or a 360. and so
it's like i kind of missed the boat and
and um and i was like look the show is
fun like i i i
i don't hate on it and i but i
and it made me appreciate
that there's probably a [ __ ] ton of
people watching obi-wan right now that's
their first ever star wars thing and
like this [ __ ] awesome true it's kind
of unfathomable but you're right
it seems unfathomable from the inside
yeah but we've learned this already from
the prequels and we've learned it like
how many people heard about grogu and
we're like i guess i should check that
out totally right baby yoda and and
we're just like oh my god cutest thing
i've ever seen and then i watch based on
that yeah
i bet over the half of the audience of
obi-wan are watching it and thinking of
it as a sequel
rather than a prequel
like i bet there's a large contingent of
the audience
who
because they're primary they see it as
like episode 3.5 and not four point
negative five i have a lot of love for
both of those trilogies and i feel like
i perspective wise
i'm looking at it as a sequel
but that's because so much as well
hayden christensen specifically is what
made me do that it's not just that it's
right obi-wan i mean yeah ewan mcgregor
is obviously tied to the prequels but
the fact that hayden christensen was so
much in the marketing is that in my head
it is a sequel and not a prequel
but that i bet austin your i assume your
default would be that you're watching a
prequel series right that you're
watching something that's a prequel to
new hope
uh
i guess i i don't know to me i really
just saw it as exactly down the mount
down the middle uh i i really have a
full hypothesis
i'm just i'm i'm i'm realizing i also
think
part of maybe what breaks my heart about
the show
is that rogue one
the combination of rogue one and jedi
fall in order i think exposed to me that
i think my favorite
star wars
era window of time is between three and
four
like the heyday of the empire it seems
to be
the most quintessential what star wars
is do you watch clone wars right
i've seen about half of clone wars i
have not seen the back half of climate
change but i i i
incredible that's the thing i i i
started watching it only in like the
last year because i it was one of those
things that i
somehow
again as a die-hard star wars nut it was
weird that that was a giant hole in my
yeah you definitely should finish it
it's very good and also makes the
prequels better i think i like them more
having watched that whole series
it adds in a lot of context that the
prequels just didn't bother with for
some reason
points uh as a side note but kind of
peripheral or ten like uh
related adjacent to the uh
to clone wars and the prequels was i
thought it was cool to have
tamura what's his name morrison as a
disgruntled veteran clone trooper in
episode two
um like as a as a way to kind of tie it
all together just fully
i don't know that to me as a little as a
little moment i was like that's
there's something there like that that's
that's that's a bit of world building
you know
fingers out stretch yeah those kinds of
details i like
um i have to run
so this is gonna be a slightly shorter
episode uh hopefully we have troy next
week to talk about love death and robots
because yeah his episode
his episode of course uh the most famous
person on that episode
of course
um and otherwise yeah just for context
we are recording this before the state
of play so if news dropped the reason
that we didn't talk about it
is that we don't know what happened
we need to yes is that starting right
now yeah
um